hey guys i'm ryan right i'm jerry i'm
dance Iver so we're gonna watch the
trailer well not the trip yeah trailer
yeah
Mortal Kombat X gameplay trailer a lot
of people have been asking us to watch
this so we're gonna watch this right now
and check it out three guys for the
first time on the channel three dudes
this is awesome
this is really awesome so we can like
bro out we can bro out let's what part
dicks out yeah I was gonna real guys we
could split real guys do right they
talked about sports Lee okay yeah sorry
I know nothing but females who don't
want to have sex with me well I mean the
only difference here is that we're not
female yeah that's true we could talk
about the girls we still don't want to
have sex with you so how is Lauren here
been warned
hmm you ever been into Lauren no really
no it's pretty cute the controller is
generic controller when is when is there
too much we're god okay this game looks
pretty [ __ ] sweet
oh yeah dude big guy with drawn back
what just a good body no bring me a
corpse oh my god
my substr always getting his ass kicked
how is he not finished
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
nice noggin smiling
that looks sweet those fatalities I
haven't wanted to play a fighting game
that bad in a long [ __ ] time
that looks well worth it I am terrible
like terrible at Mortal Kombat and I
really want that game no idea I came
pretty good at fighting games man cuz I
fight in real life I mean actually I did
say he's a [ __ ] bottom masher you and
Lauren maybe you will launch it I'll go
out on a limb here and say actual
fighting does not like I play a little
guitar and guitar hero is nothing like
that oh yeah well yeah sure that's fair
I don't think it carries over it does
defend me on this um yes most definitely
have you not thrown a chain whip into a
dude and pulled out there hurt fair
point
I don't know that was Tuesday for me
somebody's building like a desk out yeah
can you shut that door because that
person's being rude and we're trying to
make a video here and it's really
bothering me just rip off does he not
know that we're very professional here
yeah this is real filmmaking at its best
right now he's ruining it as well
what more can you say man [ __ ]
fighting looks awesome and I they really
improved the way they fight since back
in the day
yeah well the the stage is worth like
the fourth stage that they were fighting
in you know normally Mortal Kombat's
always kind of had this sort of like
feel like you're on a 2d plane yeah
exactly that one felt like you were like
walking through the forest kicking this
dude's ass hmm
yeah and it's awesome like there are
times where they grab like people and
just throw them or when he's like
flipping on the tree like that is [ __ ]
yeah cool if I had to kick an ass I
would probably want to do it in the
forest oh absolutely
oh by the sea I want to kick someone's
ass on the beach yeah you know I know as
Tekken
as any Gordeau game jokes references
more no jokes
yeah Dead or Alive beach volleyball it's
a game oh I remember when that came out
it was such a big deal and why don't we
whip our dicks out
don't want you guys know well if you're
new to the channel whip your dick out if
you're new to the channel subscribe
subscribe you could subscribe and with
that dick out actually that would be
cool you could whip your dick out and
then hit the you know the cursor yeah be
whatever you're left clicking and
exclaiming yeah oh he's waving his face
I thought he was holding okay nevermind
let's do some shadow Torian Porter hmm
he said can I get a shout out and
subscription I'm a big fan you know what
man
I will subscribe to your channel hold me
to it cuz in case I forget to do it I'm
sorry but I will do it well he's a big
fan this is your shout out to it what
are you like 10 years old don't matter
don't matter shout out shout out to you
that's right man that's right and if you
are 10 start working in math start
working at practice what does that mean
that means work the magic on the ladies
that time right Cameron Owens I don't
want to shout out okay no shout out
moving up alright but you guys should
totally say my name out loud because
it's a pretty badass name also you
should point out that it starts with a
k' cameron
owens it's a hard cut starts with a KKK
there's no way you could be gay
Shana fools does not work they do not
realize what I was saying yeah yeah it's
good though
Cameron will never in any circumstance
be confused force Ameren so that's good
damn it every time I see Cameron I
always see salmon but this Cameron's got
it down yeah hard K hashtag smiley face
I think he's part of the KKK don't just
a cute yeah maybe not not something
about thumbnail salesmen three diamonds
two bars
he said you sir are [ __ ] hilarious
plus one sub and like he subbed and
liked it because of the Godzilla movie
review I did yeah that's right guys
that's right people love me or maybe or
maybe he means he's now your submissive
and this is like a bondage relationship
whip out your dick let's do this
tonight's theme
whippin out your dick run Diamond run
run fast and run hard
damnit you should have said that I
walked into that we walked right into
that one
[ __ ] Dan